Technology will play potentially the role
just after the culture, the people, so the
people have to have that will, they have to
have the interest, and technology is probably
the next leading indicator or the next leading
source that will lead change.
The ideas behind biomass, the ideas behind
clean coal- a clean coal plant is pretty amazing.
There are so many interesting advancements
happening in technology that are at the fringe
that are now being very funded.
Just even in the past 18 months there's been
a massive shift.
It's been happening for a long time.
Vinod Khosla, John Doerr, Kleiner Perkins--
These are major investment VC houses, venture
capital houses, that have been funding this
so huge Google-esque or Google-size shift's
about to happen in that area.
The one that is most intriguing to me is all
the stuff happening kind of in the biomass
area.
It's just really interesting, the idea that
we don't necessarily have to build more coal
plants, more effective pipes for electricity
to be flowing.
The idea of an out-of-the-box solution that
is regionally based where people buy and consume
products and food and everything else and
then it all goes back in to the energy to
create energy, that's pretty radical.
I like that.